[Musique étrangère] ce
qui reste en fait,
euh, dans une situation où nous n'avons plus
accès à l'UE
signifiait que nous devions réellement essayer de
trouver une solution
et heureusement pour nous nos nouveaux voisins et
nos bons amis dans le même comté de
Cheshire
euh  plus grand que nous a tendu la main George et
Joseph guérisseur est le nom de l'
entreprise ils sont la troisième génération de
fromagers ils ont tendu la main et mis
leur bras autour de l'épaule et ont dit
tu sais que nous pouvons t'aider
[Musique]
merci
une fois le  pays a décidé qu'il
voulait quitter l'UE.
sur nous avons dû investir en
termes d'entités étrangères et de
réseaux logistiques, mais nous devons juste nous
y mettre maintenant et nous devons tirer le
meilleur parti d'une mauvaise ou d'une situation difficile
étrangère
[Musique]
notre entreprise et  chaque entreprise au
Royaume-Uni, en particulier les petites
entreprises, le coût de l'électricité est
à son plus haut niveau en
tant que producteur de fromage, alors oui, nous sommes
massivement affectés par le fait que l'
augmentation du prix du lait est la
plus élevée depuis une génération le coût de  l'
agriculture est maintenant la plus élevée
depuis plus de 60 ans
[Musique]
merci